Sky's Katarina vitotsi has this report a
warning it contains images of the
conditions colea was found in
on the morning of October 10 2020 Kaylee
tipford wouldn't wake up
what you're about to hear is the 999
call between an ambulance operator and
Kaylee's father Alan tipford who was in
the family home in Newtown Wales
then
can you
so so I need you to get her onto the
floor there can you lay a class on your
back on the floor decorations
when paramedics arrived Kaylee was
already dead
still lying on her bed surrounded by
rubbish junk food cartons and
incontinence pads stained with urine
her father told police because of covert
lockdowns they hadn't taken their
daughter to a doctor
and Kaylee hadn't returned to school
after it reopened
the teen described by her teachers as
Lively and fiercely independent despite
her disability was more than 22 stone at
the time of her death
Pathologists say she died from
complications linked to her obesity
Kaylee tipford's mother Sarah Lloyd
Jones had already pleaded guilty to her
manslaughter due to gross negligence but
Kaylee's father Alan tetford denied that
same charge saying that especially as
his daughter got older her care was the
responsibility of her mother
but a jury found Alan tetford guilty of
manslaughter by gross neglect the scale
of neglect was significant
truly shocking the neglect had clearly
been ongoing for a prolonged period of
time
a Child Services review has been
launched into how a vulnerable girl came
to die in conditions described as unfit
for an animal
Catherine avatoxy Sky News Paris Wales